mais non mais kg - turin mais sinon il
n'aurait pas confusion mais tu leur est
promis d'en goûter donc assez mûrs mais
je ne veux pas peur mais je t'assure
qu'il est il est vraiment excellent
casimir je refuse françois qui
s'adaptera temps s'étonne pas des
meilleures que j'ai jamais préparé non
non non et non
tu me dis toujours pourtant qu'il ne
faut jamais refusé ce que l'on ne
connaît pas oui c'est vrai mais là c'est
différent mort alors tout peut bien
faire un effort
tant pis pour 10 mais je ne mangerai pas
de gloubiboulga je n'ai jamais vu
quelqu'un d'aussi têtu pour fin j'en ai
déjà mangé une fois quelle mauvaise foi
alors tu arrêt à peine posé le doigt
dessus quand tu faisais déjà la grimace
avant de l'avoir mis sur ta langue mais
je l'avais goûter non faut vraiment
apprécié il faut en manger au moins
trois grande cuillère je n'en mangerai
pas tu en mangeras non casimir tu
devrais respecter mes goûts comme je
respecte les tient bon écoute je te
prendrai que si tu n'aime pas ça je ne
tends proposerait plus jamais et
jeunesse ces premiers c'est promis si tu
as mangé trois cuillères de nom en avons
3 avec 2 on ne peut pas apprécier
d'accord bon alors 3 cuillères les pas
trop grosse non non non allez alors
attention une cuillère pour julie
oh que ces nouvelles j'ai jamais rien
mangé d'aussi toujours la pièce une
deuxième cuillère pour monsieur lui
sinon ben non non non pas du tout il
commence à apprécier la délicieuse
saveur du merveilleux gloubiboulga aux
curieux 500 d'apprécier si l'on te
criait tu évoques depuis le fond du
jardin
julie c'est affreux mais arrête toi
non non il a promis d'en manger 3
cuillères en charge
il paraît que c'était la troisième
cuillère quand on commence à trouver ça
beau très bien bon courage
paris deuxième cuillère pour le farceur
[Applaudissements]
donc cet ignoble ans que ces mêmes états
unis tu es sûr que c'est du gloubiboulga
oui
c'est même un délicieux gloubiboulga
dira peut-être un tout petit peu prendre
moutarde mais d'un autre côté il pas
excuse moi je t'avais oublier françois
donne moi la troisième cuillère de
gloubiboulga comment ça allait mais ça
quand vous une grande affluence au no no
no no no no no surtout parler
dépêche-toi de mener la troisième
cuillère pour que ce soit fini
le plus vite possible je suis sûr
françois mais bien sûr je promis tu vas
voir celle là qui la trouvera très beau
y aller une troisième puis hier pour
monsieur du snob up
[Musique]
alors elles seront soit qu'est ce qui
t'arrive
dis moi quelque chose et paul casey mais
en réseau coup il a dit vrai à la
troisième cuillère le gloubiboulga est
bien meilleure tu vois julie j'ai
toujours dit qu'il n'y avait rien de
meilleur que le gloubiboulga
évidemment c'est peut-être un peu lourd
à digérer et des images archives ou
faire quelque chose pour que j'ai mal je
dis soit sorti raccompagne mois chez moi
il faut que j'aille me coucher je suis
malade
bonjour concernant la laddh c'est que
c'est pourtant du gloubiboulga premier
choix enfin casimir françois n'a pas à
l'estomac de casimir us
évidemment c'est une petite n'a été mis
en garde le kiosque et essai de
distraire les enfants à mieux que je
revienne je comprends pas françois est
vraiment douyère j'avais juste omis un
petit morceau de savon de marseille pour
lui faire une farce et il est malade aux
bombes et maintenant il faut que je dise
très les enfants à les enfants venaient
là prenez vous asseoir venez venez tous
venez on va faire un jeu vous voulez
bien
on va faire un jeu nous allons jouer à
augusta quoi pourrait-on bien jouer
projet une idée j'ai une idée je vais
vous donner la recette du gloubiboulga
d'accord bon pour faire un excellent
gloubiboulga il vous faut d'abord du
chocolat au lait de préférence à vous le
rappelez vous le mélanger à de la
confiture de fraises vous télé des
bananes vous mélangez bien le tout
ensuite vous rajoutez la moutarde et les
saucisses de toulouse tiède mais cru un
important bond et pour améliorer vous
mettez un petit morceau de savon de
marseille
non non quand je suis bête non ça
c'était une blague que j'avais faire
françois excusez moi vous avez compris
qu'est ce qu'on va faire maintenant
bon ben je recommence alors une deuxième
fois alors tout faire un excellent
gloubiboulga il faut du chocolat au lait
que vous rappelez bien fin
[Musique]
or là là là julie n'est toujours pas là
bon bah écoutez je vais vous randonnez
pour la quinzième fois la route 7 pour
réussir un super extra gloubiboulga
géant délicieux 1
alors il faut d'abord du chocolat au
lait de préférence à bout qu'est-ce que
ça julie comment va françois il va
beaucoup mieux mais pourquoi les enfants
sont utiles tu avais promis de les
amuser
je ne fais que ça je leur donne pour la
15e fois la recette du gloubiboulga avec
ou sans savon de marseille
comment ratu deviner c'était très simple
j'ai cherché toute la matinée mon
morceau de savon de marseille que
j'avais acheté hier soir et comme
françois m'a dit que ce qui l'avait
rendue malade dans le gloubiboulga
c'était le goût du savon de marseille
j'ai tout compris oh c'était juste une
petite farce résultats françois et
malades et les enfants s'ennuient
j'imagine pas du tout l'îlot z'enfants
comme ça moi non plus mais si tu veux tu
peux nous chanter comme en tulle
imagine-toi l'île aux enfants les
enfants venez écouter julie on est tous
unis va chanter sa chance
m
tha
à
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
avec beaucoup de couleurs
avec beaucoup de tout ça
vous rêvez
blondel
non
j'y vois des filles et garçons casimir
chante à sa chanson
en soins
une volée facile
[Musique]
je l'aimé ou pas ce que je veux
mais je l'aurais mieux que si j'étais un
an
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans le kiosque les poupées
[Applaudissements]
leur serine citron fraise est grand a
[Musique]
à
un papillon passer le temps
assis sur un banc
géo à regarder
butiner les sabres
mais je mourrais veut pas si je peux
je jouerai mieux peu si j'étais sa main
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
art
non